[Music]
if you tried to pay for something with a
piece of paper you might run into some
trouble unless of course the piece of
paper was a hundred dollar bill but what
is it that makes that bill so much more
interesting and valuable than other
pieces of paper after all there's not
much you can do with it you can't eat it
you can't build things with it and
burning it is actually illegal so what's
the big deal of course you probably know
the answer a hundred dollar bill is
printed by the government and designated
as official currency while other pieces
of paper are not but that's just what
makes them legal
what makes $100 bill valuable on the
other hand is how many or few of them
are around throughout history most
currency including the US dollar was
linked to valuable commodities and the
amount of it in circulation depended on
a government's gold or silver reserves
but after the u.s. abolished the system
in 1971 the dollar became what is known
as fiat money meaning not linked to any
external resource but relying instead
solely on government policy to decide
how much currency to print so which
branch of our government sets this
policy the executive the legislative or
the judicial the surprising answer is
none of the above
in fact monetary policy is set by an
independent Federal Reserve System or
the Fed made up of twelve regional banks
in major cities around the country its
Board of Governors which is appointed by
the President and confirmed by the
Senate reports to Congress and all of
the feds profit goes into the US
Treasury but to keep the Fed from being
influenced by the day-to-day
vicissitudes of politics it is not under
the direct control of any branch of
government so why doesn't the Fed just
decide to print infinite hundred-dollar
bills to make everyone happy and rich
well because then the bills wouldn't be
worth anything think about the purpose
of currency which is to be exchanged for
goods and services if the total amount
of currency in circulation increases
faster than the total value of goods and
services in the economy then each
individual piece will be able to buy a
smaller portion of those things than
before this is called inflation on the
other hand if the money supply remains
the same while more goods
services are produced each dollars value
would increase in a process known as
deflation so which is worse too much
inflation means that the money in your
wallet today will be worth less tomorrow
making you want to spend it right away
so while this would stimulate business
it would also encourage over consumption
or hoarding commodities like food and
fuel raising their prices and leading to
consumer shortages and even more
inflation
but deflation would make people want to
hold on to their money and a decrease in
consumer spending would reduce business
profits leading to more unemployment and
a further decrease in spending causing
the economy to keep shrinking so most
economists believe that well too much of
either is dangerous
a small consistent amount of inflation
is necessary to encourage economic
growth the feck uses vast amount of
economic data to determine how much
currency should be in circulation
including previous rates of inflation
international trends and the
unemployment rate like in the story of
Goldilocks they need to get the numbers
just right in order to stimulate growth
and keep people employed without letting
inflation reach disruptive levels the
Fed not only determines how much that
paper in your wallet is worth but also
your chances of getting or keeping the
job where you earn it
[Music]